hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer questions from
one of my readers Cape Wilson who's
YouTube viewer and his question is he is
an eighteen-year-old entrepreneur and he
wants to become a business owner who
wants to sell smartphones and tablets
and his father wants him to become a
doctor and go to school and become a
physician so was asking my advice on
what to do next so my best advice for
you is actually look at the story of
Michael Dell now when I was starting my
business I found a lot of inspiration
from famous entrepreneurs and that gave
me ideas for what to do and also the
motivation to keep going and keep trying
new things so del story is very similar
to what you're going through right now
he was in University and studying to
become a physician and that's what his
parents wanted him to do his father was
an orthodontist and he really wanted to
not do that and start his own business
selling computers and so what he
convinced his father to do was he would
take one summer off of school from May
to August he would work on his business
and try to get it going and generate
sales and the deal was if he made a
success of himself between May and
August he could leave school and run his
business if he wasn't successful he'd
have to go back to school in September
and become a physician now fortunate for
della worked out and he knows business
took off and now he's one of the most
successful entrepreneurs in the world so
maybe you can replicate that success as
well I would talk to your father and see
if you can make something similar so
from may to august work in your business
pour everything you can into it and you
know if it works i'll be able to keep
doing that for you to have the biggest
chance of success i would say try to
start finding a customer so if you're
selling smartphones and tablets who's
going to buy this and try to go to
business i would think as a stronger
market than consumers consumers could be
one off a lot harder to make individual
sales where a business owner if you can
solve a real need for them could buy
lots of your products lots of inventory
from you and can basically put you in
the business so I've invested a lot of
time and energy I wouldn't try to spend
a lot of
me by go out and put a lot of your sweat
into it blood sweat and tears get the
business going and try to get into the
business market to generate some
immediate cash flow and circle in your
business so I hope that helps I love to
hear everybody's thoughts and feedback
please give the video a thumbs up and
leave a comment under the video to it
helps me keep going and making more of
these videos so thank you and stay tuned
for the next episode
you